no jaywalking on my watch Boston cops
are going online
posing as punk rockers in order to bust
do-it-yourself music shows before they
begin a key suck
Green Day rules it's part of a citywide
crackdown parent basement and warehouse
shows spurred by recently passed
nuisance control ordinance ensure
officers could simply wait for noise
complaints boring but catfishing is so
much more fun that mozz jump it's gonna
be wicked v weston MA especially if you
can expense a hot topic shopping spree
to get into character it's hard to tell
what's worse the suffocating of the
indie music scene the wasting of police
resources or the fake punk talk the cops
do break balls something wicked here
what's the adjust for Saturday night
Preston man that's Google Plus user Joe
sly who's widely suspected of being an
undercover Boston cop and not just
because of his name or because he refers
to shows as concerts the stalker points
out his avatar is one of the first
images that appears in a Google search
for punk rocker so maybe we should be
thankful that cops aren't wasting even
more time trying to come across like
real punks but come on no cops have
better things to do more than half of
the murders committed in Boston last
year have yet to be solved and that's
long after the police department
launched a special effort to solve more
homicides so instead of playing pretend
online maybe cops could spend more time
in the real world
catching real criminals followed the
show on Twitter submit your nominees for
next month and check out my Claussen
this month's featured follower
you